[Music]
you know what we heard about today
you've probably heard about this too I
came in this morning and people were
talking bout the fact that well I guess
last night's American Idol caught some
of our fans attention because they said
there was a contestant this was all over
the Internet I guess there's a
contestant who people claim looks like a
cross between an D s and me and actually
a bunch of people on the internet have
been saying they've been referring to
him as our love child people should take
a biology class yeah well anyway I guess
they're gonna be in that Star Wars game
Andy the guy's name is Ben Harrison and
let's take a look here he is
[Applause]
usually when people say that looks like
you they're wrong and it's actually
insulting but that kid really does look
like if you took my head when I was
younger and put your face on yeah it
looks a little that way I thought maybe
we would take a second here on the show
and test this theory to see if it's true
so let's put here's call but there's Ben
let's put him on one side of the screen
and II hold your face still okay let me
get in there let me get in alright put
me in there put me in there
[Applause]
all right forget Ben just stick with us
this is high this is how I'm gonna do
the show from now on I'm the perfect
human being
hi beautiful
I think I'll scratch my cheek
all right that is too freaky I can't
handle that anymore you make it make it
stop for God's sakes
exactly what millions of dollars of
Technology was meant for that's what